لا يبدو المشهد الداخلي في اسرائيل بافضل
حالاته رغم خوضها الحرب الاكثر صعوبه في
تاريخها كما سبق وان ردد ذلك الكثير من
قادتها السياسيين والعسكريين منذ السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي التقلبات والتطورات التي
شهدها ملف المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في غزه
على مدار 100 يوم من الحرب كانت لربما
المثال الابرز على اتساع الشرخي بين شريحه
واسعه من الاسرائيليين وقيادتهم السياسيه
وصلت حد اتهام عائلات المحتجزين نتنياهو
بعدم المبالاه بارواح ابنائهم وتعمد
التخلص منهم خصوصا مع تسبب الغارات
الاسرائيليه في قتل بعضهم بل وسقوط ثلاثه
منهم برصاص جيشهم رغم تمكنهم من الهرب من
ايدي
اسرم فشل العائلات في انتزاع وعود قاطعه
من مجلس الحرب بسرعه التوصل الى صفقه
تبادل تعيد ابنائهم على قيد الحياه دفعها
لتصعيد احتجاجاتها في الشارع وصولا الى
اعتصامات امام وزاره الدفاع لتنضم اليهم
لاحقا حشود من الاسرائيليين رفعوا شعارات
لا تتبنى مطالب العائلات فقط بل تدعو
لرحيل رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
والذهاب لانتخابات المبكره حتى قبل ان تضع
الحرب اوزارها مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي لم
يكن هو الاخر في من عن تصدعات من اخر
ففضلا عن غياب الانسجام بين نتنياهو ووزير
الدفاع يواف جالانت وعضو مجلس الحرب بني
جانس وضبابيه الصوره بشان مرحله ما بعد
الحرب على غزه فان شرخا اخر اخذ بالاتساع
بين القياده السياسيه والعسكريه في ظل
تكرار الهجوم من قبل وزراء من اليمين
المتشدد على رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هيرتس هاليفي لا سما بعد تشكيله فريقا
للتحقيق في احداث السابع من اكتوبر ما دفع
العشرات من القيادات العسكريه السابقه في
اسرائيل الى توجيه رساله الى هاليفي عبروا
فيها عن دعمهم له واعربوا عن حزنهم بسبب
الجبهه التي فتحها الوزراء لهزيمه الجيش
ورئيس اركانه فيما طالب بعضهم عضو مجلس
الحرب بن جانس بالاستقاله لتمهيد الطريق
امام اسقاط حكومه نتنياهو المتهم من قبل
خصومه بالسعي للاحتفاظ بمنصبه مهما كان
الثمن حتى لو كان ذلك عبر اطاله امد الحرب
والتضحيه بارواح المزيد من الجنود والاسرى
وتحميل الاخفاقات الميدانيه لقاده الجيش
فهو يريد انقاذ نفسه لا انقاذ اسرائيل كما
صرح بذلك رئيس المعارضه يا اير لابيد في
المقابل ادلى اعضاء في المجلس الوزاري
المصغر بتصريحات صحفيه شككوا فيها باداء
الجيش معتبرين انه لم يحقق حتى الان ايا
من اهداف الحرب الرئيسيه فهو لم يحرر
الاسرى ولم يدمر القدرات العسكريه لحركه
حماس ولم يصل الى قاده الصف الاول كما ان
غالبيه الانفاق لم تدمر
بعد وبحسب محللين عسكريين فان مسار
العمليات في غزه وارتفاع اعداد القتل
والمعاقين والتباين بين ما يعلن امام
الشاشات وما تكشف عنه وقائع الميدان عوامل
القت بظلالها الثقيله على الشارع
الاسرائيلي وعلى تماسك الجبهه الداخليه
وسرعت من المعركه التي كان يعتقد انها
ستندلع في اليوم التالي لانتهاء الحرب
بشان من يتحمل مسؤوليه الاخفاق في السابع
من اكتوبر الجيش ام الحكومه الامر الذي قد
يجعل من محاولات نتنياهو لتجاهل العواصف
من حوله والرهان على شعارات توحيد الصفوف
ووضع الخلافات جانبا محل
شك